[Musique]
il nous fallait un miracle et nous en
avons créé cette merveilleuse petite
créature sera bientôt une révolution
dans l'industrie de l'élevage nos super
cochon ne seront pas seulement
magnifique et bien gras ils laisseront
aussi une empreinte environnementale la
plus faible possible consommeront peu de
nourriture et produiront mois
d'excréments et le plus important leur
chair devra avoir bon coup
[Musique]
hu
déjà on aime les animaux tu sais notre
objectif est de révéler ce que fait
l'iran dont il sauve et objat et de te
la ramener très vite
ico dix années de préparation nous
sommes sur le point de lancer un produit
qui va nourrir des millions de gens et
qu'est-ce qui se passe l'adorable fille
de fait un bateau sous des trucs
faut que tu saches que la situation
n'est pas très bonne
quel dommage qu'on doive raconter tous
ces petits pots parc
mesdames et messieurs je vous demande
d'applaudir
sam
key
là
[Musique]